partito si sono d'accordo
ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla nuova
puntata di cucina buttata abbiamo fatto
tre settimane fondamentalmente di salato
adesso arrivato il momento di tornare al
dolce e non un dolce qualsiasi una delle
cose che mi ha sempre fatto più gola e
ha risvegliato in me una sorta di
sessualità che sono le ciambelle fritte
quindi qualcosa col buco
ero sicuro che la resina che qualsiasi
cosa sia afflitto e coperto di zucchero
secondo me non può che non essere
benedetto dagli dei
prima di partire vorrei subito parla di
una cosa importantissima una cosa è
stata ditta tantissime volte perché
teniamo gli sportelli aperti è arrivato
forse il momento per vedere perché lo
facciamo che cosa accadrebbe se gli
chiedessimo innanzitutto la sagoma tina
enrico e gianmarco io credo che si usano
scena romantiche data un bacio
appassionato che si stanno dando davvero
e inoltre deve fare quelle cose lì
enrico la luce enrico so che fa
impazzire in realtà fa passare anche
meno che gianmarco continua attaccare e
staccare le cose ma che problema si
sente sicuro
guarda come si intorno al bene vero la
felpa col gay ma possiamo iniziare
diciamo gli ingredienti per fare le
ciambelle fritte i primi tutti alla
farina per fare le ciambelle serve la
farina up regionale le ciambelle è ricco
ma non lo un taglio e chiffon mai per
fare la ciambella ci vuole la farina la
farina
l'asta bella ci vuole anche la ricotta
150 grammi 2 uova 90 grammi di zucchero
20 ml di succo d'arancia o di liquore
scelta noi abbiamo preso il succo
d'arancia park and ride la casa è stato
comunque perché tutte le ciambelle di
esse ha comunque poi state antipatici 8
grammi di lievito per il cielo salotto
bene appesa di morgan del miele che
turbato da zia se bravo la scorza di
un'arancia da cui sembrava tipo un
limone arancione una ragione sale noi
leggiamo i vostri commenti quindi
aggiungeremo il sale rosa dell'himalaya
da oggi al nostro destino
abbiamo letto un commento che è già
marco riesce a trovare questo per fare
un pochino di informazioni visto che
siete in tantissimi in ogni fatto
abbiamo usato sale rosa dicevate no non
lo faranno facile ma denti perché perché
perché finché non è arrivato un commento
che ci ha fatto un attimo cambiare idea
e ciò soprattutto illuminati possiamo
inquadrare gianmarco illuminato dice che
il sale rosa contiene cadmio che è un
metallo tossico non ha nessuno scopo nel
metabolismo umano
ero oltretutto solitamente il sale rosa
non è gli ho dato quindi smette di usare
quel cup risale rosa e comprati quello
italiano e gli ho dato che costa pure
meno ok lo piante devo dire illuminante
grazie silvia per le tue parole dolci e
abbiamo con i della sale alimentari fino
che gli ho dato moby tirando che sarei
diventato e poi avremo bisogno di olio
di arachidi in abbondanza per poterle
friggere l'olio contiene olio prima di
partire però volevo ringraziare il sito
a questo prendendo la ricetta visto che
noi non creiamo un mezzo ricetta che sia
nostra e lo diciamo che ho voglia di
dolce ringraziamo quindi puntoit fritte
senza limitazione anche se
evito stai tranquillo ci penso io a fare
cose darlene carlo c'è pure una video
ricetta che non vedremo perché vogliamo
vedere se il potere delle parole riesce
a superare quello delle immagini
partiamo cioè il potere delle parole
scritte riesce a far comprendere senza
bisogno che qualcuno dimostri cose di
fare
sì ma non è compresa e veloci qui
infatti a fare un vero ci può mettere un
po del tuo in questo format battista
persone 8 mostra nella nostra bulla
aggiungiamo subito ii e v o fatto una
[Musica]
rosso il gioco possiamo andare avanti
a questo punto mettiamo la buccia
grattugiata di un'arancia cerchiamo una
che magari ed è casa mia e quella con la
sagra saranno accendino vabbè basta dai
c'è marco è peggiorato carati sei mesi
tra fidenza e non ero per capirlo tra di
noi siamo altro cambio contiene questa
rancia e non so nemmeno cosa sia il
cadmio quindi un metallo tossico cioè
nel sale cesta il metallo è proprio
tigrati pure la forchetta o un genio sei
paesi metto in metallo che non poteva
mettere contestate quanto si regredisce
speri in compagnia e a questo punto
aggiungiamo seguito 90 grammi di
zucchero frusta a mano e sbattiamo
ti ha detto è sbattiamo dai in programma
di incontrare ufficiale comunque la
cucina e il sesso sono collegati e
facciamo un attimo sentire il suono
meravigliosa del fava il cibo sia a me
sembrano 150 g di ricotta sono dello
pesata vaccina macina ricorda la cina
grazie jam e di vacca e c'è da ridere
ricorda di vaccari a lui sa come 3 ride
adulti in basso aggiungiamo consistenza
stupenda sotto la fausta il lievito per
dolci e a più riprese la farina io ho
già adesso anche il concetto sbatto la
frusta e passò alla ii card comunque
avete scordato il succo d'arancia 20
milioni
tu hai messo la farina giustozzi e prima
della farina dove metterlo no un pizzico
di sale fino e aiutato mi fanno male
mani vuoi in cambio però già minuto
tramando un cambio c'è stato due secondi
ci penso io
siete voi quelli fisicati in famiglia
hai una struttura buona comunque
rimettiamolo in rack struttura buona
struttura grazie
il cambio cugino mio posso portarti
qualcosa mi chiede lancer deliziosa non
rischiamo di guardarla un po gianni tu
non rischi mai niente sei bravissimo dai
proprio un complimento
tu hai l'altezza che imparare alla
famiglia 190 sparo su al micropene è
ancora molto umido aspetta che ci riceve
da vi prende un po di farina gentilmente
con in mano
non vorrei avere il cervello di john mar
forse messo troppo su come questa
ricetta servono sette chili farina da
qui sembra che sta facendo altro
l'immagine di se in realtà quelle scene
ok adesso perillo ciambella fritta
infariniamo tutto bella league mentre
prepariamo le nostre ciambelle andiamo a
riscaldare l'olio cosa importantissima
non far superare all'olio 170 gradi
perché sennò rischià di bruciarti
l'esterno e tenerti l'interno ancora col
doc la boccia metterlo dentro
mentre supporto dai ancora sette anni io
son sicurezza qualcuno che ride poi se
lo fate non vi vergognate poi quando
andate a dormire la sera disse ridendo
prendiamo un pezzetto e ricaveremo da
quest'anno sta un pochino di ciambelle
poi prenderemo l'altro pezzetto e faremo
le ciambelle utilizzando però un altro
metodo che suggeriscono i preoccupa
pasta il secondo faticosi torciglioni lo
spessore è di 12 centimetri in quello
suggerito cerchiamolo questo e 12 cm di
spessore perché ceca pentimento il kopa
pasta a 40 tant'è che in zona superano
170mila detto scappa dai 174 200
abbiamo preso questo casino per filtrare
il tè e lo utilizziamo per fare il gip
non d'italia contro la temperatura quale
siamo questo 160 e butterei lo sai
procedere la cosa che rende che quando
li metti vanno sul fondo e poi dopo un
po salgono una due e tre sembrava nasser
fanno a galla carinissima come si stanno
confinarlo guarda quale come si stanno
gonfiando il miracolo della vita tu stai
a fa delle ciambelline in un patto dono
saprei pensate forse una cosa molto più
difficile se non po troppo cotto direi a
185 alla facciamo un solo tentativo con
ciambelle più spesse questo è carina 164
sì ragazzi questi casi il termometro da
cucina e la svolta vi lascio sotto nei
link ci sono termometri per ricchi per
poveri per borghesi me vi prendete
quello che volete se vi va quello strass
trans tra consiglio perché torna sempre
utile
wow questo sapere le fette sono stupende
un'importante estetica prima volta che
le facciamo quando ero troppo sottili e
ora che sono di uno spessore tra un
centimetro e 2 cm vogliamo però a onor
della scienza e perché non tutti a lungo
papa sta a casa provare il metodo del
attorcigliare quindi dare una svegliata
alla vasta su bella facciamola a filo
intanto che attorciglia qua
volevo ricordarvi di metterci un bel
pollice in su per il buco se mi sta
piacendo questo questo video e sono
tutte fracese avere nei commenti quali
sono altre ricette che ti piacerebbe
vedere visto che in realtà non l'ho
detto all'inizio ma questa qui è una
ricetta che c'è stata suggerita da uno
di voi ma in realtà un bel pop queste
raccomandata quanto cioè scommetti che
io non ce la faccio più a fare in questa
cosa mi faccio uno e basta
la ciambellina di me dove stavano scena
sentimenti link dei coppa pasta comprate
da in coppa vasta non fate i portieri e
tarallo 3 fortissima seguiamo l'ha fatta
svogliatamente però questa è con una
mano una mano che sfiori to sola dentro
una stanza e tutto il mondo guarin
voluto dire vasco sono i commenti
posso fare una cosa una ciambella
gigante una ragazza in fila
oddio sembrano due occhi con la bocca
spalancata mamma mia
in poco tempo fa comunque una merenda
per un bel po di peso da gente meno male
che voi ve sfondate tutto il figurone e
gustatevelo ragazzi gustatevelo sapete
perché ai posteri
[Risate]
no ha rotto il per questo che pensiamo
sotto il mio regalo che ho fatto a
guglielmo sentire in colpa e giusto
perché l'unica via è il karma cioè
dottorcup tutto il tempo e la fine ora
non lo sai che con l'attak funziona
lo spero da ex a rotolo lago adams da ma
vuoto emotivo che fanno di camera fallo
vedere in camera sì diciamo che è un
pene di cavo adesso prendiamo una
ciambella immergiamo nel miele
spennelliamo spennelliamo e poi sarà
perché un soldato ma poi sapete le
ciambelle al bar quali sono solo quelle
interamente due rate ma gianmarco non
caccia i dolci ma una laurea incidente
gravissimo ma veramente ti sei fatto
fregare così è solo un ladro vuoi vedere
la foto lo so quello che dici tu ma
questo tipo di ciambella mi date per
favore un piatto non ci stiamo rompendo
sullo zucchero bianco blu bianco
programmi ancora su mito prodotto per
capirlo che facciamo tutte quante ci
vediamo appena sono fatte al momento
della verità l'assaggio in cina alla tua
[Musica]
giammarco che dice bona vuol dire che è
un piatto di vino due stelle michelin
non riconobbe parole anzi il brutto
anatroccolo no per il gigante come
sapore leggermente diversa
queste ceva più zucchero io
personalmente trovo buonissime può
calcolare che non sono lievitate quindi
assomigliano di più a delle ciambelline
fatta al forno piuttosto che fritte non
è che dentro ai la sufficienza sembra
più proprio una merendina buonissima
travolta aggiungere
zucchero parte lo tira un bel sentivo
dire noi chiediamo che la prossima
domenica sempre con un altro cucina
buttata ciao ciao